it's tough and it's tough you know
carson wentz has put a ton into the
season and to get to this moment and
especially you know the things that he's
gone through
uh
and
it's a tough call to go out there and
get to play and play off game with
special and
and i can't thank them enough for their
support
and
it was it was a
heck of a ride i left it all out there i
know that much
josh mccount is awesome and he had
comments like that when he went on
injured reserve last year about his
teammates and how much he missed and
he's like i just he lets it all out
there he does 40 years old had never
played in a playoff game in his career
and the reason he got to play is the
subject of significant controversy and
angst by eagles fans the hit from
janaevian clowney sure knocked carson
wentz out of the game but ultimately was
diagnosed as a concussion look is it a
dirty play i don't know carson once
becomes a runner and
genevieve and clowny just drops the you
know
look should it have been flagged you
lower your helmet to initiate contact
and you initiate contact that's the rule
and that's what he did lowered his
helmet to initiate contact and initiated
contact it should have been a foul it'll
be interesting to see if he's fine
probably right yeah i don't think it was
egregious enough that he would have been
ejected right but the bottom line is
this the damage is done yeah i mean you
can you can call it a dirty hit you can
find him you can suspend him it doesn't
change the fact that
it was an opportunity to take a shot at
the quarterback and it knocked him out
of the game and it changed everything
for the eagles after that well it
changed everything for all of us i mean
come on i mean the reason we were
watching that game was carson wentz and
russell wilson that i mean especially
with philadelphia carson wentz says by
far and away the best player on the
eagles the last month of the year i mean
i don't think any of us i think all of
us thought that the eagles were gonna
win it was gonna have to be with carson
wentz making magic and making a few
plays down the stretch so it ruined it
for us from that standpoint now i don't
think it's a dirty play i don't do i
think it should be penalized do i think
you should be fine okay maybe but i
think what he's doing is i think this is
just a guy that's playing to the whistle
playing really physical
he's trying to make the quarterback pay
for move running with the ball let me
and that's the thing would he have
tackled a running back like that um i
think he would have i do i think he's
going all out but you just said you just
said he's making the quarterback pay for
running well i think he's just not
treating him any differently i think
he's going that's different than making
the quarter what's your answer is he not
treating him differently or is he making
the quarterback pay for okay all right
so don't know my answer would be i think
he's trying to put a lick on anybody he
can put a lick on no matter who they are
i think that's what demi on clown is
trying to do he said after the game i
was just playing fast it was a bang bang
play i don't want to hurt nobody in this
league i've been down the injury road
it's not fun my intentions weren't to
hurt him that's a great player over
there i hope he's okay it was just a
small hit i don't know about that
everybody was going crazy i'm like i
didn't even hit him that hard i was like
why are people booing i didn't think it
was that crazy of a hit i fell on him a
little bit but i didn't think it was
that big of a hit look the bottom line
is he lowered his helmet lower initiated
contact with it and then that should
have been flagged if they're gonna flag
that and the rules still on the books
that's an instance where you flag it and
and it will be interesting to see when
the nfl discloses the fines that
flow from these games sure will he be
fined and
i have a feeling he will be i think you
should
i will be it's one of those though where
i look at it and i go if i'm on the
eagles yeah i'm disappointed and i'm
probably going it's a little dirty if
i'm the seattle seahawks i'm going man i
love you debbie on clowny he just plays
physical and brings it which he does
this is the type of energy he brings to
a game again there was a few plays he
made yesterday mike that again f the
plays up it doesn't matter it just
doesn't go on the stat his energy his
ability to direct plays all of that but
i don't think he was doing that with
like intent of i want to knock this guy
out i think he's doing it more of i'm a
psycho defensive lineman who runs around
like this every game and i'm going to
make anybody pay with maybe his eyes
getting brighter when singing exactly
quarterback we talk about we talk all
the time about how so many teams coach
their defensive players to be scared of
hitting a quarterback this may be a
product of pete carroll and the
defensive staff in seattle saying when
that guy decides to run yeah you make
him pay make him pay he's no different
than any other running yeah i'd coach my
team like that but i don't think i i
don't think he does that move on a
running back if that's miles sanders or
boston scott i don't think he does it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports